I'm working with acceleration here other than the force
because acceleration is already offered by the rest of the program,
and I said before, I can reuse one of these accelerations,
which is why I start the initial acceleration in this variable code, well, initial acceleration.
Here comes Euler as we know it, these two lines,
and then I'll form the average of the velocities to go to the next step
and I'll form the average of the accelerations to go to the next step and that's all.
If you run that program, you see two series of data.
The upper one is the one that we know, the errors of the forward Euler's method,
and the lower one are the errors of Heun's method and you see these are really low.
So this method really rocks out.
On top of that, you see that this seems to be a parabola.
While Euler's method almost forms a line here, Heun's method forms a parabola.
So it's good and it even gets better as we shrink the step size.
There is a price to pay--we call that acceleration function twice.
If you look at what we get for that price, that really pays off.